Betsy DeVos is Donald Trump's selection
for Secretary of Education she was
destroyed yesterday this is one of the
most embarrassing performances I've seen
at a cabinet confirmation hearing I
would argue probably ever this is a
total gong show hilarity and
simultaneously horrifying and scary the
big picture problem is Betsy DeVos is
going to be Secretary of Education and
she doesn't even really believe in the
concept of funding secular public
schools before I play a couple of clips
for you let me set the stage to explain
to you how nutty this billionaire is in
a 2001 interview she said I'll just put
the quote up on the screen and this
relates to to religion and education
this is from Mother Jones in a 2001
interview for The Gathering a group
focused on advancing Christian faith
through philanthropy she and her husband
offered a rare public glimpse of their
views asked whether Christian schools
should continue to rely on philanthropic
dollars rather than pushing for taxpayer
money through vouchers Betsy DeVos
replied quote there are not enough
philanthropic dollars in America to fund
what is currently the need in education
versus what is currently being spent
every year on education in this country
our desire is to confront the culture in
ways that will continue to advance God's
kingdom that is the incoming Secretary
of Education priority with regard to
funding and donating to education is
anybody shocked that the religious nut
who likes charter schools and has five
billion might not be the best person to
figure out how to improve public school
education for everybody and it became
very clear during these confirmation
hearings that she has no clue what the
hell is going on let's start with Al
Franken Al Franken utterly embarrassed
Betsy DeVos and asked a very simple
question about a prevalent issue in
education which is proficiency versus
growth this is a total cringe moment if
you're allergic to cringe I would skip
the next
and 44 seconds because it is really
difficult to watch take a look at this
this is brings me to the issue of
proficiency which the senator cited
versus growth and I would like your your
views on the relative advantage of
prophit measuring doing assessments and
using them to measure proficiency or to
measure measure growth good luck Thank
You senator for that question I think if
I'm understanding your question
correctly which your own proficiency I
would I would also correlate it to
competency and mastery so that you each
student is measured according to the
advancement that they're making in each
subject area well that's gross that's
not proficiency so in other words the
growth they're making is in growth the
proficiency is if the arbitrary standard
reached a level the proficiency is if
they've reached a like third grade level
for reading etc no I'm talking about the
debate between proficiency and growth
yeah what your thoughts are on them well
I was just asking to clarify yeah then
well this is this is a subject that is
has been debated in the education
community for years and I've I've
advocated growth as the chairman and
every member of this committee knows
because with proficiency catchers ignore
the kids at the top who are not gonna
fall below proficiency and they ignore
the kid at the bottom who no matter what
they do will never get to proficiency so
I've been an advocate of growth yeah but
it surprises me that you don't know this
issue I'm not surprised
yeah that's difficult to watch isn't it
I almost start to feel bad for her
except then I remember she's got five
billion and would destroy public
education so then I'm like okay maybe
she deserves to be embarrassed here that
is difficult to watch yeah it's very
difficult to watch I mean okay I we've
seen this before with with Trump when he
doesn't understand kind of the
fundamental purpose of an issue or a
topic that he's
better though at delaying and not
answering she just didn't clearly
exposed Pat that she no idea what's
going on but he also has Kellyanne yes
yes and given that it's with Al Franken
it kind of reminds me of his SNL days
and yes just a parody right no it's
indistinguishable from a parody okay
next Betsy DeVos said she's not going to
rule out adding a lot of guns to schools
because of grizzly bears do you think
that guns have any place in or around
schools I think that's best left to
locales and states to decide if the
underlying question is you say that you
can't say definitively today that guns
shouldn't be in schools well I will
refer back to Senator Enzi and several
that he was talking about in Wapiti
Wyoming I think probably there I would
imagine that there's probably a gun in
the school to protect from potential
Grizzlies President President Trump
moves forward with his plan to ban will
you support that proposal I will support
what the president-elect does if she's
Secretary of Education or secretary of
local wildlife I mean potential grizzly
bears in wampa t Wapiti what's the name
of that town wampa T Wyoming and here's
a back and forth with senator Tim Kaine
on whether she supports equal
accountability for all schools and I
can't even explain this it's about as
bad as the Al Franken exchange do you
think that schools that receive k-12
schools that receive government funding
should meet the same accountability
standards our own standards I all
schools that receive public funding
should be accountable yes it should meet
the same accountability standards yes
although you have different
accountability standards between
traditional traditional public schools
and charter schools but I'm really
interested in this how's everybody man a
level playing field
so public public charter private k12
schools if they receive taxpayer funding
they should meet the same accountability
standard yes they should be very
transparent with the information and
parents should have that information
first and foremost and if
firmed will you insist upon that equal
accountability in any k-12 school or
educational program that receives
federal funding whether public public
charter or private I support
accountability equal accountability for
all schools that receive federal funding
I support accountability oh is that it
yes or no that's a I support
accountability do you not want to answer
my question I support accountability let
me ask you this I think all schools that
receive taxpayer funding should be
equally accountable do you agree with me
or not
well they don't they're not today but I
think they should you agree with me or
not well no because you don't agree with
me let me uh the firmware the latest
firmware update is glitchy because she's
stuck on repeat again like Marco Rubio
she doesn't want to commit to an answer
Pat because she doesn't understand the
question yeah I mean this is what
happens when you choose someone for a
role like this based on their ties and
their wealth rather than their
experience she just doesn't know how to
artfully answer that question and the
cherry on top
Betsy devices family has made
contributions that support so-called gay
conversion therapy something that
fortunately has been banned for kids in
California today's show is brought to
you by go daddy where you can buy your
own domain name build a website or use
any of Go Daddy's business tools you can
save 30 percent at Tri godaddy.com slash
David GoDaddy has actually been the
official host of the David Pakman show
web site for many many many years the
24/7 customer support has been a very
good thing for us I've called them at
really odd times when we've had website
issues and they are always available
they are the largest domain registrar
and whether you have a new idea you're
an established business you're creating
a personal website or moving your large
enterprise site over to GoDaddy they can
do it all 13 million customers try it
and get 30% off at try go daddy.com
slash David